- [Teacher] I'm now
going to give an overview
on the beginnings of Islam.
And regardless of whether you are a part
of an Islamic culture, you
are a practicing Muslim,
or you believe in the Islamic traditions,
it's valuable to learn about
the beginnings of Islam
because, today, nearly one-fourth
of the world's population
either is a practicing Muslim
or has grown up in an Islamic tradition.
Now, the beginnings of
Islam really are centered
on the life and the revelations
of the Muslim prophet, Muhammad.
Now, the term, Islam, means surrender
and, as we'll see, a lot of
the revelations of Muhammad
are about surrendering to God,
about the oneness of God,
about not worshiping idols.
And to put Muhammad in
perspective, on a timeline,
I have other significant
biblical figures, here,
and these are important
not just to get a reference
towards Christianity and Judaism,
but because, according
to Islamic tradition,
Islam is built on top of the teachings
of Abraham, or the teachings
of Moses and the Torah,
and the teachings of Jesus.
Muslims believe that the
Quran is the Final Testament,
so to speak.
To get some context,
Muhammad was born is 6th Century Arabia,
and 6th Century Arabia
was an interesting place.
In many other videos, we've talked
about various empires
around the Mediterranean,
around the Mesopotamia and Persia.
And even on this map,
in the time of Muhammad,
you see significant empires,
the Byzantine Empire,
the Eastern Roman Empire.
You have Sasanid Persia.
But Arabia was never really consolidated,
or ruled, by a formal, or most of Arabia,
by a formal government or a formal empire.
The rule of law in most of Arabia,
and the world in which
Muhammad was born into,
was a tribal world
where you were protected
by your tribe and it was really the laws
of vendetta and revenge that
kept certain things in check,
but also would lead to a lot
of wars and a lot of violence.
And within Arabia, there were many folks
who are Bedouins, who were nomadic people,
who traveled through the desert
allowing their livestock to
graze on whatever suitable land
they found, but you
also had settled people
in places like Mecca.
You had people who'd settled
and started agriculture
around oases.
Remember, most of the Arabian
Peninsula is really desert.
And, Muhammad was born into a fairly,
or a very prominent family in Mecca.
He was born to the Quraysh tribe,
and the Quraysh tribe was
essentially in control of Mecca,
and Mecca was a very
powerful city to control
because it was a religious
center for the region.
This is the Kaaba, which exists today,
and is the center of Islamic worship.
And, at the time, it
housed hundreds of idols
which were important to the
various tribes and people
of Arabia at the time.
And so, you can imagine
as they did the pilgrimage
towards Mecca to worship their idols,
it also benefited the economy
of Mecca in a significant way.
And not only was Muhammad
born into this powerful tribe,
he was born into one of
the most powerful clans
within that tribe,
and within one of the most
powerful houses within that clan.
But even though he was born
into this very powerful family,
clan, and tribe, his early
life was quite difficult.
His father died right before he was born.
His mother dies at the
age of six years old,
and, then, his grandfather,
who then takes custody of him,
and by most accounts, he
doesn't get a lot of privileges.
When you're a member of a tribe,
you're essentially orphaned.
The tribe is doing, essentially,
just the base necessities
to keep you alive.
But then his grandfather dies
when he is eight years old,
and he becomes, he goes under the custody
of his uncle, Abu Talib.
Now, as he grows older,
he does learn a skill.
He essentially becomes a merchant.
He goes on trading journeys
with his uncle, Abu Talib,
to places like Syria.
And, as he does that,
according to Islamic tradition,
he gets a very favorable reputation.
He gets these titles like,
Al-Amin, the trustworthy one,
or Al-Sadiq, the truthful.
Now, he continues doing
that until the age of 25.
At 25 years old, something
very interesting happens.
A very wealthy widow, arguably
one of the wealthiest people
in all of Mecca, who runs
a vast trading enterprise,
Khadija, who is 40 years old,
she employs Muhammad and, apparently,
is so impressed by his honesty,
by his ability to be trustworthy,
that she propose to him,
and, remember, she's 40.
This would be her third
marriage, and he is 25,
and he accepts the proposal.
Now, this is significant because
as we'll see in this video
and the next, Khadija is the
first one to follow Muhammad,
or believe in Muhammad's revelations.
So, he continues to work with his wife,
arguably work for his wife,
and, then, in 610, he's now 40 years old,
he is praying in a cave
on the outskirts of Mecca,
and while he's praying, he is purported
to get his first revelation from God,
according to Islamic traditions.
And that first revelation,
and this is the mountain where
it is purported to happen,
the Mountain of Light, Jabal an-Nour.
This is the cave, Cave Hira.
The first revelation is,
"Proclaim, in the name of thy Lord
"and Cherisher, Who created man,
"out of a clot of congealed blood.
"Proclaim, and thy Lord is most bountiful,
"who taught by the pen,
"taught man that which he knew not."
And so Muhammad, according
to Islamic accounts,
he's kind of very concerned by this.
He does not view himself as a preacher.
He does not view himself as someone
who should be a prophet,
and he goes to Khadija,
and he's worried, and Khadija takes him
to her Christian cousin,
who reassures Muhammad,
who tells Muhammad that he
believes that he is a prophet
in the tradition of Abraham and Moses.
And so, that, to some degree,
makes Muhammad feel a little bit better,
and he doesn't have some
revelations for awhile,
and he becomes concerned.
But then, he eventually starts
to have many, many revelations,
but he keeps it to himself, at first.
But, roughly three years later, he starts
to publicly preach these revelations.
So, these revelations which really talk
about the oneness of God.
There's no God but God.
It's very appealing especially to some
of the economically lower strata,
but you could also imagine,
it's very, very threatening
to the establishment of Mecca.
You have to remember, the
establishment of Mecca,
it revolves around the
worship of these idols,
and now you have this
guy of the Quraysh tribe,
the tribe that worships Hubal,
the tribe that is in charge of Mecca,
that benefits from all these people
worshiping these various idols.
He's know saying that,
"Idol worship is a sin."
He's saying that there's not God but God,
that all of these idols are false idols.
And so, the Quraysh tribe,
Muhammad's own tribe,
begins to significantly
persecute the early Muslims.
So much so, that many of
the early Muslims have
to migrate from Mecca
to the Kingdom of Axum,
which was ruled by a Christian king,
who protects them the Quraysh tribe.
This is now modern-day
Ethopia, or Eritrea.
And so, things are not going
well for these early Muslims.
They're being targeted
by the Quraysh tribe.
They're being killed.
They're being tortured.
And then, things get
even worse for Muhammad.
In 619, you have the death
of his wife, Khadija.
And, just to get a sense
of how powerful Khadija was
to Muhammad, we have
this quote that we get
from the Hadith, which are
accounts of Muhammad's life
and sayings, and it tell us,
"God Almighty never
granted me anyone better
"in this life than her.
"She accepted me when people rejected me,
"she believed in me
when people doubted me,
"she shared her wealth with
me when people deprived me,
"and God granted me
children only through her."
This is, once again,
according to the sayings
or the life of Muhammad
as accounted for by one of the Hadith.
And not only did his wife,
who up to that time was his only wife,
die and was a significant figure,
but in that same year,
his uncle also dies.
So, you can imagine this year, 619,
often referred to as the Year of Sorrows,
it's a fairly low point for Muhammad.
He's been preaching for about,
or he's been getting these revelations
and preaching for around nine years, now,
and things are not looking good.